la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
présidentielle qui distribué nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
tu l'envoies point il est donc adopté
sous les réserves d'usage madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres puis chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement notre séance
est retransmis sur Public Sénat et sur
notre site internet
chacun sera attentif à observer
les principes qui sont des principes
cardinaux ici le respect il s'agisse du
respect des uns ou des autres et respect
plus mathématique qui est celui du temps
de parole
je vais donner immédiatement la parole
au président Patrick cannaire pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain vous avez la parole monsieur
le président
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre
nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la
première fois à votre demande de 27
juillet dernier
et je vous avais fait part de ma grande
préoccupation sur la situation sociale
de la rentrée de septembre et je vous
avais proposé une revalorisation
significative du SMIC mais surtout
l'organisation d'une grande conférence
salariale pour anticiper les difficultés
financières prévisibles de l'immense
majorité de nos concitoyens
ma vie répondu que telle ne serait pas
votre choix
privilégiant la seule solution des
accords de branche
aujourd'hui le désordre s'installe la
colère gronde et les premières victimes
sont les salariés obligés de prendre
leur voiture la crise des carburants que
traverse notre pays et le premier étage
d'une crise sociale généralisée qui est
sur son pas de tir
les inégalités se creusent et ce n'est
qu'un début faire preuve d'autoritarisme
en réquisitionnant les salariés sans
responsabiliser les employeurs ne
permettra pas de revenir à une paix
sociale à laquelle nous aspirons aucune
prime même Macron limitée dans le temps
et dans l'espace ne remplacera une
revalorisation durable des salaires vous
n’anticipez plus vous ne faites plus que
pallier et mal par des rustines
extrêmement coûteuses pour la solidarité
nationale que vous convoquez pour mieux
exonérer les plus aisés de nos
concitoyens les pompes à essence
s'assèchent le pouvoir d'achat est
siphonné par l'inflation mais les
dividendes eux continuent à ruisseler
madame la Première ministre cette
situation est absurde certaines
entreprises peuvent tripler leur
bénéfices profitant de la crise actuelle
mais sans augmenter leurs salariés mais
sans contribuer à l'effort national ma
question est donc simple face à cette
aberration allez-vous choisir le camp de
la résignation ou le camp du combat pour
la justice sociale
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre madame la
Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
président cannaire alors je vous
remercie monsieur le Président pour vos
propos parfaitement équilibrés et
modérée
s'agissant des profits exceptionnels
j'ai le plaisir de vous indiquer que
vous pourrez dans le cadre de l'examen
du projet de loi de finances examiné une
disposition qui doit permettre de taxer
les profits exceptionnels notamment des
compagnies pétrolières donc je n'ai pas
d'autres que vous aurez à coeur de voter
cette disposition
et je vous précise également monsieur le
Président que moi aussi j'échange
régulièrement avec des salariés avec des
fonctionnaires avec les Français qui
travaillent et moi aussi je parle avec
les organisations syndicales et puis
j'ai changé également régulièrement avec
des chefs d'entreprise et tous me disent
la même chose les Français veulent vivre
de leur travail
cette conviction c'est de la mienne et
c'est aussi celle de mon gouvernement le
travail c'est la dignité c'est
l'émancipation et c'est bien pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des Français
que nous avons pris des mesures fortes
je pense notamment aux bouclier
tarifaire qui est la mesure la plus
protectrice d'Europe et depuis plus de 5
ans nous agissons pour que le travail
paye toujours mieux je pense notamment à
la suppression pour que le travail paye
toujours mieux je pense notamment à la
suppression de certaines cotisations
sociales ou à l'augmentation de la prime
d'activité et puis cet été nous avons
pris des mesures nous allons y venir
messieurs les sénateurs
cet été nous avons pris des mesures
supplémentaires en revalorisant la prime
d'activité en créant la prime de partage
de la valeur en facilitant le déblocage
de l'épargne salariale ces dispositifs
ce sont les salariés et les entreprises
qui avancent ensemble ce sont des
salariés qui bénéficient des richesses
qu'il contribuent à créer alors monsieur
le Président vous me parlez de salaire
je voudrais rappeler qu'en France au
niveau interprofessionnel nous avons le
dispositif le plus protecteur du salaire
minimum avec les hausses automatiques le
SMIC en un an a été revalorisé de 8%, je
vous rappelle que l'inflation est de 6%,
sauf erreur de ma part 8% c'est plus que
6%
les flations en France est de 6%
monsieur le sénateur naturellement
naturellement cette revalorisation
automatique du SMIC doit conduire les
branches professionnelles à revoir leur
grille salariale depuis le début de
l'année plus de 500 accords de branches
sur les salaires ont été signés il y en
avait eu que 418 sur toute l'année 2019
et je rappelle également que le
Parlement a voté cet été une disposition
qui accélère les négociations dans les
branches dont les minima sont inférieurs
au SMIC donc la dynamique elle est là
elle doit se prolonger car je suis
d'accord toutes les entreprises qui le
peuvent doivent augmenter les salaires à
fortiori dans la période d'inflation que
nous connaissons mais monsieur le
Président Kanner je sais que vous le
savez c'est du dialogue social que
viendra la réponse le dialogue social
j'y crois profondément mais le dialogue
social c'est se mettre autour de la
table c'est respecté les accords
majoritaires c'est chercher des
compromis ça n'est pas bloqué le pays
alors oui mon gouvernement croit au
dialogue social nous prenons nos
responsabilités pour que ce dialogue
social puisse se tenir et que les
résultats en soi respectés je vous
remercie
monsieur le président kener
[Applaudissements]
très second madame ministre tout d'abord
vous savez bien que l'inflation pour les
ménages les plus modestes n'est pas de
6% elle est de 13 à 14% par rapport au
panier moyen de ces de ces ménages
premièrement deuxièmement vous me parlez
de dialogue social comment voulez-vous
faire comprendre les salariés de Total
qui demandent une valorisation de 10% 7%
pour l'inflation 3% pour les profils
d'entreprise que leur patron monsieur
pouyanet a augmenté de 52% son salaire
en 2021 pour atteindre 500.000 euros par
mois voilà ce qui est injuste et vous ne
le combattez pas vous êtes faible avec
l'effort et fort avec les faibles
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue et rigole
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole mon chers collègues merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les Français vivent depuis
maintenant plus de 2 ans dans un
contexte particulièrement anxiogène
enchaînant crise sanitaire crise
économique guerre en Europe inflation
générale tout cela avec une capacité de
résilience remarquable qu'il est
important de souligner
s'expliquant par les grèves des
raffineries mais aussi par une
augmentation malanticipée de la
consommation générée par les remises à
la pompe la pénurie de carburant est
venue donner le coup de grâce à une
partie de la population qui ressent
particulièrement la facture sociale et
territoriale
les Français qui n'ont aucun accès aux
transports en commun et non d'autres
moyens de locomotion que la voiture bien
sûr il a eu des comportements parfois
irresponsables de la part des usagers
qui se sont ruées sur les stocks
d'essence remplissant leur jerrican
après avoir rempli leur réservoir sans
doute les mêmes qui avaient à l'époque
épuisé les stocks de papier toilette de
farine ou de moutarde mais la réalité
est là et c'est avec cette réalité que
les toits doit composer les stations
services sont prises d'assaut les
Français font face à des difficultés
pour se déplacer des professionnels ne
peuvent plus travailler correctement y
compris dans les services essentiels à
la population
je sais que ce n'est pas au gouvernement
de discuter les salaires des grévistes
en tout cas il n'est pas l'acteur
principal de ses négociations mais il
est question ici de problèmes
d'approvisionnement sur un bien
stratégique qui pourrait potentiellement
paralyser jusqu'au service de santé et
de sécurité de notre pays
l'État a donc l'obligation de s'en mêler
après avoir mis en place quelques
mesures malheureusement insuffisantes
vous avez effectivement annoncé hier que
les préfectures pourraient
réquisitionner les salariés de certaines
raffineries en grève
pouvez-vous nous préciser comment cette
réquisition va se dérouler ne
craignez-vous pas que la justice vous
oppose la liberté fondamentale du droit
de grève comme cela a déjà été le cas en
2010 et si tel était le cas quels autres
pistes envisagez-vous tout en évitant
d'apporter davantage de gasoil russe
pour répondre à la demande
pour vous répondre la parole est
ministre déléguée en charge au nouveau
démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement monsieur Véran
retour de micro mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs messieurs le sénateur il
rigole merci pour votre merci pour votre
question vous l'avez dit le gouvernement
agit là où il peut et là où il doit agir
depuis le début de cette crise sociale
qui conduit à des situations de tension
réelle dans de nombreux départements
d'autres pays équipénalise des millions
de nos concitoyens pour aller au travail
pour aller faire leurs courses amener
leurs enfants à l'école parfois même
vous l'avez dit vous-même se soigner
nous avons d'abord suppléer au carburant
qui ne pouvait pas sortir des centres de
dépôt en apportant massivement et
notamment depuis la Belgique des
carburants à destination de la région
Hauts-de-France nous avons également
puisé dans nos réserves stratégiques de
carburant et démultiplier les
camions-citernes il y a des noria
organisés de manière à pouvoir suppléer
là aussi aux difficultés rencontrées par
de nombreuses stations services nous
avons conscience que cela ne suffit pas
à régler le problème et ce que la
première ministre souhaite ardemment
depuis le premier jour c'est que le
dialogue social se fasse dans de bonnes
conditions qui l'aboutissent pour que
les blocages cessent or il y a deux cas
de figure il y a quatre figure du groupe
Epson notamment avec des centres de
dépôt de carburant situés en Normandie
où là la CFDT et d'autres syndicats
réformistes ont signé avec leur
employeur un accord majoritaire cet
accord n'a pas été respecté ni soutenu
par la CGT qui a annoncé souhaité
continuer le blocage l'État prend alors
sa responsabilité en demandant au préfet
de prendre des arrêtés de réquisition
dans les plus brefs délais qui devraient
être opérationnels aujourd'hui de
manière à bloquer l'accès au dépôt de
carburant de port Jérôme et améliorer la
situation dans les jours qui viennent
dans l'autre cas de figure le groupe de
groupe Total a annoncé ouvrir les
négociations et les discussions sur les
salaires la CGT semble avoir décidé et
il faut on semble avoir décidé de
participer en tout cas au premier
réunion nous restons extrêmement
attentifs à l'évolution de ces
discussions et aux décisions d'arrêt du
blocage que nous appelons de nos vœux
sans quoi là aussi la première ministre
l'a annoncé l'état prendra ses
responsabilités et décidera des
positions nécessaires pour que chacun
puisse retrouver son quotidien dans des
conditions de normalité ça prendra
évidemment du temps plusieurs jours
chacun peut imaginer que le temps de
rouvrir des raffineries de pouvoir
extraire du carburant des dépôts mais la
situation s'améliorera de façon visible
dans les jours qui viennent chez
de la parole de notre collect Thomas
dessus pour le groupe écologie c'est
solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre dans un peu plus d'un mois
commencera la 22e Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar
sans préjugés de la sélection finale
cette année nous avons une équipe de
très haut niveau et cette coupe du monde
aurait dû être une très belle fête pour
la France pourtant on le voit il y a un
malaise qui monte pour ne pas dire du
dégoût y compris chez certains des plus
fervents supporters des Bleus en réalité
nous sommes face à un dilemme une
troisième étoile sur le maillot bleu
vaut-elle toutes les compromissions car
des compromissions il y en a eu et il y
en a encore en 2010 Kylian Mbappe
n'avait que 12 ans mais à cette époque
là Nicolas Sarkozy œuvrait déjà avec
succès pour que la monarchie cathari se
voit attribuer l'organisation de
l'événement 12 ans plus tard on
s'apprête à jouer la plus grande
compétition de football sur les cadavres
de 6500 travailleurs qui ont participé à
la construction des stades climatisés 12
ans plus tard les droits humains n'ont
pas progressé au Qatar les minorités
sexuelles sont toujours persécutés les
femmes ne sont pas libres l'esclavage
continue
12 ans plus tard le climat prend la
trajectoire du Kaos global et on
continue d'organiser des grands
événements sportifs dans le déni
climatique en dépit de toutes les
alertes de toutes les catastrophes de
tous les emballements et de tous les
drames qui surviennent alors vous me
direz madame la ministre vous n'êtes pas
comptable des compromission passées mais
la France s'apprête à exporter dès
demain son savoir-faire en matière de
sécurité en le mettant au service de la
dictature cathari avec l'envoi de 220
gendarmes mais agent de sécurité civile
tous des hommes bien sûr pour ne choquer
pour ne pas choquer le rigorisme
religieux des émirs pourtant madame la
ministre au-delà du rayonnement de nos
équipes nationales le sport français
devrait être un réel vecteur
d'engagement en faveur des droits
humains et du climat ma question est
donc la même que celle que je posais à
votre prédécesseur il y a quelques mois
à l'occasion des JO au pays du génocide
ouigourd si nos joueurs n'ont pas assumé
les choix politiques de la France
allez-vous de votre côté au moins
boycotter diplomatiquement cette Coupe
du Monde de la honte et de la
compromission et allez-vous enfin
engager votre ministère dans une réelle
diplomatie sportive au service du climat
et des droits humains
pour vous répondre la parole de Kev Adam
la ministre des Sports et des Jeux
Olympiques paralympiques
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
dessus un rappel en effet liminaire si
vous me le permettez la décision prise
par la FIFA
d'attribuer la Coupe du Monde 2022 au
Qatar a été prise il y a 12 ans
dans un tout autre contexte notre
urgence écologique elle est bien entendu
plus prégnante que jamais et nous
souhaitons que le
Qatar face tout ce qu'il doit pour tenir
l'objectif de neutralité carbone qu'il a
affiché pour le Mondial
il a indiqué le pays pouvoir s'appuyer
pour cela sur un système de transport en
commun ambitieux d'ailleurs bâti pour
l'occasion avec l'expertise française et
des investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables de tout premier plan
au-delà de ça dans ce chemin vers le
Mondial nous voulons évidemment
encourager le Qatar à poursuivre son
engagement pour mettre pleinement en
oeuvre l'accord de Paris est réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
sommes d'ailleurs engagés dans des
coopérations techniques pour accélérer
les efforts de ce pays dans ce sens
en prévision de la cop27 de charmelcher
nous espérons que le Qatar pourra
soumettre une contribution nationale
réhaussée et une stratégie de long terme
davantage alignée sur l'objectif de
limitation de l'objectif de
réchauffement climatique à 1,5 degrés
s'agissant des droits humains je crois
que le combat de notre pays en
bilatérale en multilatérales dans
l'enceinte de l'OIT et avec les ONG dans
human right Swatch dont Amnesty
internationale porte très haut ce combat
il a marqué de premier progrès en 2018
et en 2020 à travers une législation qui
évolue mais c'est progrès sont tout à
fait insuffisants et nous veillons à
chacune des interactions à ce pays à
promouvoir le respect de l'ensemble des
droits humains mais vous avez raison
derrière votre question c'est bien le
modèle futur que nous voulons pour nos
grands événements sportifs
internationaux et les critères qui
président à leur choix alors
localisation au cahier des charges de
ces événements
de premier espoirs nous entendons la
FIFA qui appelle de ses vœux se
renforcement des critères
environnementaux dans les appels
d'offres pour les enfants
pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques des jeux les plus
écologiques de l'histoire nous tiendrons
cet engagement de la même façon que dans
la foulée du plan de sobriété
énergétique portée par la terminez
terminez
voilà la parole est à madame Colette
mélo pour le groupe des indépendants
République et territoires
j'ai piqué la place du président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé une autre pénurie
menace la France celle des médicaments
l'alerte lancée récemment par l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament et
des produits de santé concernent les
traitements les plus courants du diabète
de type 2 mais c'est l'arbre qui cache
la forêt depuis janvier les ruptures
d'approvisionnement des officines
augmente de manière constante et sont en
passent d'être multipliés par deux
au-delà des antidiabétiques les
médicaments qui luttent contre
l'hypertension ou les médicaments
anticancéreux sont également concernés
par ces tensions tout comme de plus en
plus de médicaments de manière plus
générale les princesses sous les
médicaments qui n'ont pas d'alternative
thérapeutiques connaissent ces
difficultés les témoignages émanant du
terrain sont claires il manque de plus
en plus de molécules chez les
pharmaciens
en 2018 déjà notre collègue Jean-Pierre
de colle avait soulevé ce problème lors
d'une mission d'information demandée par
le groupe les indépendants des pistes
d'amélioration de notre système avaient
été proposé les causes de ces pénuries
sont multiples et la gravation de la
situation est due en partie aux fortes
tensions déclenchées par la pandémie de
covid-19 et plus récemment par la guerre
en Ukraine beaucoup de nos médicaments
viennent d'Asie les matières premières
pour les fabriquer sont quasiment toutes
hors Union Européenne nos chaînes de
distribution ne sont pas assez efficaces
c'est un problème de souveraineté pour
la France et pour l'Europe nous devons
produire nos médicaments les ruptures de
stock et les tensions sur les
approvisionnements nous fragilisent nous
risquons des drames humains nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter
monsieur le ministre quelles sont les
réponses conjoncturelles et surtout
structurels que vous comptez apporter
pour lutter contre ces pénuries
l'échelons européens n'est-il pas
incontournable
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
Monsieur François Brown monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs et
sénateurs madame la sénatrice mélo le
médicament est un secteur stratégique
essentiel pour notre pays qui répond à
plusieurs enjeux renforcer notre
capacité d'innovation développer nos
capacités de production et favoriser
cette augmentation de ses capacités en
attirant des industries étrangères dans
notre pays également vous l'avez dit un
enjeu de souveraineté nationale mais
aussi un enjeu de souveraineté au sein
de l'Europe tout cela pour garantir un
meilleur accès à nos concitoyens et un
meilleur approvisionnement pour éviter
ces pénuries
le gouvernement est fortement engagé
dans la suite du président de la
République pour soutenir l'industrie du
médicament à titre d'exemple mais vous
le savez des engagements forts pour
l'innovation maintenir l'innovation que
ce soit en termes financier avec 10
milliards d'euros qui ont été mis dans
le cas du plan 2030 et des plans à côté
et également dans le cadre de la faveur
pour favoriser
l'accès aux médicaments très innovants
pour nos concitoyens
c'est un secteur en forte croissance
nous respectons là aussi les engagements
du Président de la République devant
l'industrie du médicament nous allons
même au-delà et l'année prochaine c'est
800 millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
seront mis dans cette industrie par la
Sécurité sociale tout ceci n'est pas
incompatible pour autant avec les
efforts juste et proportionnés nous
demandons à cette industrie
nous devons en responsabilité favoriser
son développement mais je le rappelle
c'est bien budget de la Sécurité sociale
le budget des Français qui paye cette
industrie et le gouvernement s'est
engagé à ne pas augmenter l'impôt et ne
pas diminuer non plus les droits de nos
concitoyens nous avons pour autant
entendu les remontées fortes de ce
secteur nous travaillons avec eux sur
une restructuration structurelle de
l'ensemble du secteur et sur la
meilleure moyen pour passer l'année 2023
qui est devant nous
merci de donner la parole à madame la
Présidente Sophie prima pour le groupe
les républicains
merci monsieur le président de cette
question s'adresser à madame la Première
ministre mais je crois que c'est
monsieur le ministre en industrie qui va
me répondre monsieur le ministre je veux
avec mon collègue Serge gabarit ici vous
parlez au nom de tous les chefs
d'entreprise sur tous nos territoires
qui nous cessent et qui sont tétanisés
aujourd'hui par l'explosion des coups de
l'énergie nous nous trouvons désormais
dans une situation où il est devenu
préférable pour nombre d'entreprises de
cesser de produire voire de fermer leurs
portes plutôt que de continuer à créer
des richesses car la production leur
fait perdre de l'argent certains ferment
leurs usines 2 3 4 mois certains
réduisent leur production de 25 à 30%
place leur salarié en activité partielle
à nouveau c'est notre souveraineté
industrielle économique et même
alimentaire qui est en danger tous les
secteurs sont frappés de même que toutes
les tailles d'entreprises elles font
face à cette impasse folle soit signé
des contrats à des tarifs non
soutenables économiquement soit ne rien
signer avant mois octobre comme le RA
suggéré le président de la République en
septembre dernier et se retrouver sans
contrat sans énergie sans activité au
1er janvier car sur le marché les
contrats à terme sont devenus
inexistants les offres quand elles
existent ne sont valables que quelques
heures et ne sont pas accessibles
économiquement le marché sans repère est
devenu imprévisible et personne personne
ne semble vouloir prendre la bride de ce
cheval devenu fou les chefs d'entreprise
sont seuls l'un de mes critères mais
qu'attend-il nous mourrons et nous
mourrons de morts subites alors bien sûr
un premier Bouclier a été mis en place
pour les électrons intensives et les TPE
mais je ne doute pas que vous savez
comme nous que le dimensionnement n'est
pas suffisant les critères d'éligibilité
trop strictes les boulangers quand ils
n'ont pas le bon compteur et s'ils ont
un four trop puissant sont aujourd'hui
en train de fermer aussi Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre je vous mettais
Premier ministre monsieur le ministre
aussi monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour de porter une
solution simple massive et maintenant
extrêmement rapide pour soutenir nos
entreprises
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste déléguée en charge de
l'Industrie monsieur Lescure vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la Présidente prima les alertes que vous
avez je les entends aussi je suis
régulièrement sur le terrain j'ai
rencontré des entreprises dont certaines
que vous avez mentionnées qui
effectivement aujourd'hui envisage voire
même mettre en place de l'activité
partielle pour faire face à des hausses
du prix de l'énergie explosive je sais
pas si je suis en charge de dompter le
cheval mais en tout cas je participe
avec mes collègues Bruno Le Maire en
espagnol renaché à trouver des solutions
et effectivement ces solutions nous
visons à les mettre en oeuvre dans les
jours qui viennent on ne parle plus de
semaine on en parle plus de moi on parle
de jour elles sont présentes à la fois
au niveau européen au niveau national et
même au niveau local au niveau européen
vous le savez nous travaillons pour
découpler le prix du gaz et de l'énergie
et s'assurer qu'on puisse faire baisser
y compris en intervenant sur les marchés
des dérivés pour l'année prochaine vous
l'avez dit madame la Présidente de
manière à faire baisser l'ensemble des
prix du gaz et de
pour 22 et pour 23 nous travaillons
aussi à simplifier prolonger et
amplifier le dispositif d'aide à
l'Ukraine qui a été utile pour certaines
entreprises mais qu'il avait dit n'est
aujourd'hui insuffisant dans son ampleur
et trop complexe dans ces critères nous
y travaillons là aussi avec nos
partenaires européens parce que tout ça
doit se faire au niveau européen ensuite
au niveau local moi j'ai demandé au
fonctionnaire qui sont présents dans les
territoires les commissaires aux
restructuration l'accompagnement des
entreprises d'être au plus près des
entreprises pour les aider un à négocier
avec leur fournisseur d'énergie parce
que vous l'avez dit madame la Présidente
il est hors de question qu'on n'est pas
des contrats qui soient offerts aux
entreprises nous avons signé avec Bruno
Le Maire Agnès Grégoire une charte avec
les fournisseurs d'énergie qui se sont
engagés à fournir des offres
compétitives à leurs clients si elles
leur demandent elles doivent aussi les
accompagner elles en devoir de conseils
pour les accompagner dans la durée de
manière à pouvoir les conseiller sur la
meilleure manière de dessiner leur
contrats nous intervenons à tous ces
niveaux là je voudrais aussi en profiter
pour faire un appel à la solidarité des
filières parce qu'au fond nous devons
tous contribuer à l'appui à notre
industrie qui je vous rejoins ne doit
pas être la victime collatérale de cette
guerre il faut que les distributeurs il
faut que les grands groupes il faut que
tout le monde puisse appuyer les
filières de manière à ce que l'industrie
sorte gagnante de cette crise merci
la parole est à notre collègue Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues deuxième
clou du cercueil après l'intervention de
Sophie prima cette fois-ci pour plaider
pour la filière agricole qui est
lourdement frappée par la crise
énergétique avec évidemment
l'augmentation des intrants des ruptures
de contrat d'approvisionnement d'énergie
notamment des fournisseurs alternatifs
ce secteur semble oublier alors que
d'autres sont plus attentifs à d'autres
secteurs et les agriculteurs sentent
douloureusement cette injustice le cas
par exemple de la coopérative biosher
dans l'heure 280 adhérents 26 dans
l'Orne facture énergétique
285000 euros aujourd'hui plus d'un
million si rien n'est fait ceci est
évidemment insoutenable Sophie prima a
très bien expliqué le dispositif il en
est de même pour la filière équine chers
au président Larcher et pour les jeunes
agriculteurs récemment installés qui ne
peuvent bénéficier de dispositif en
place mal adapté n'oublions pas les ici
d'agriculteurs et les nombreux drames
personnels notre souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre dont
vous êtes évidemment chargé et menacé
quelle mesure allez vous prendre et
quelle mesure avez-vous déjà prise pour
soutenir les agriculteurs dans cette
période extrêmement difficile
la parole est au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur Martino merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Goulet cette question
effectivement fait ok écho pardon à la
question qui a été posée par la
présidente prima sous le pendant
l'agriculture et agroalimentaire avec
une spécificité parfois j'y reviendrai
que la spécificité d'avoir une
saisonnalité et une incapacité en plus à
rompre la chaîne de production dans le
dans l'agriculture la situation a été
décrite n'y reviendrai pas on a
travaillé je crois avec vous madame la
sénatrice sur l'entreprise biosher
pourrait essayer de trouver des
solutions globalement quelques éléments
sur le court terme en complément ce
quasiment collègue Lescure sur le court
terme la charte qui a été signé par
l'ensemble des opérateurs pour fournir
obligatoirement une offre pour
conseiller et pour faire en sorte que la
modération puisse l'emporter deuxième
élément le niveau européen effectivement
nous attendons des réponses dans les
jours qui viennent pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse décorer les prix de
l'énergie gaz électricité parce que ça
c'est un levier puissant c'est un levier
puissant évidemment au niveau européen
nous simplifions enfin l'aide aux
énergies aux entreprises et ergo en
l'adaptant mieux à ce qui était la
réalité y compris je le dis de la
saisonnalité de les industries ou
alimentaires je pense à une filière pour
être emblématique et celle de la
betterave où on voit bien qu'il y a une
période où on a besoin de plus
d'électricité que d'autres ou d'énergie
que d'autres et le dispositif entonné
malcompte et donc on a réajusté
dispositif enfin il est massifié dans
son montant puisqu'on est passé on a
doublé pour chaque catégorie
d'entreprise de 2 à 4 millions de 25 à
50 millions et de 50 à 100 millions
enfin dernier élément et là c'est plutôt
sur le moyen long terme madame la
sénatrice on a besoin aussi de
travailler à faire en sorte vous en avez
parlé d'être moins dépendant d'un
certain nombre de facteurs de production
je pense à l'énergie et je pense aussi à
l'intérieur de l'énergie aux intrants en
particulier aux intrants azotés parce
que la situation dans laquelle l'Europe
s'est mise d'une dépendance trop
importante fait en sorte que nous avons
besoin de reconquérir cette souveraineté
donc des mesures de court terme et des
mesures d'accompagnement de moyens et
long terme pour l'ensemble des filières
agricoles et agroalimentaires et vous le
savez madame la sénatrice le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
et les ministère de l'agriculture est
quotidiennement mobilisé pour essayer de
répondre aux besoins de chacune des
filières merci
madame vous voulez
je pense qu'il faudrait
un que les
isteurs les élus mais aussi la BPI la
banque des territoires la MSA en fait
tout ce qu'on peut mettre en place pour
des mesures d'urgence et aussi la
protection des individus je pense aussi
que madame la Première ministre a
indiqué une taxe sur les super profits
je pense que ça va être bienvenu et
qu'elle servira aussi à améliorer les
dispositifs qui permettent d'indemniser
et en tous les cas de soutenir cette
filière en tous les cas sachez que nous
sommes extrêmement mobilisés qui a une
urgence je pense notamment aux jeunes
agriculteurs qui ne disposent d'aucune
ancienneté pour bénéficier des boucliers
qui sont actuellement en place donc
c'est vraiment important et c'est
vraiment urgent merci pour eux
merci de donner la parole de notre
collègue Eric Bocquet pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste merci monsieur le Président
Madame laurier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues depuis un certain temps de
compatriotes regardent avec effarons
tourner le compteur des pompes à essence
et pendant ce temps-là les actionnaires
regardent grimper les chiffres les
dividendes avec ravissement les prix des
carburants s'emballent les spéculation
sévit et totale énergie s'enrichit y
compris grâce à l'argent public du
bouclier tarifaire l'entreprise
enregistrait plus de 10 milliards de
dividendes au premier semestre de cette
année ce qui va lui d'ailleurs aux
actionnaires le 28 septembre dernier de
bénéficier d'un dividende d'exceptionnel
de 2,6 milliards d'euros total énergie
deviendra demain totale bénéfice les
salariés des groupes pétroliers
demandent légitimement leur part de
cette réussite entre guillemets et
revendique une hausse de leur salaire
la satisfaction des revendications des
salariés pour Total énergie
représenterait une somme de 140 millions
d'euros soit 1,4% des profits du sol
premier semestre monsieur le ministre je
pense qu'il est temps de faire pression
sur les directions des groupes total
énergie et exones mobiles leur demander
aimablement un geste de bonne volonté à
l'évidence cela ne suffit pas d'autant
plus que face aux salariés le
gouvernement brandit la menace
inacceptable de la réquisition
pour vous répondre la parole à Olivier
Véran porte-parole du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateurs
politiques de par les combats que vous
avez mené je vous sais plus attaché que
qui compte autre ici à la qualité du
dialogue social et au respect des
accords obtenus par le dialogue social
monsieur sénateur je vous invite à
envisager une situation qui ferait que
des syndicats majoritaires obtiennent un
accord majoritaire avec un employeur
portant sur une hausse de salaire et
qu'à l'issue de cet accord majoritaire
un syndicat non signataire non seulement
aux deux syndicats non signataires
minoritaires je crois que le dialogue
social c'est le fait majoritaire et je
crois que les communistes soutiennent
cela et je le soutiens aussi et le
gouvernement aussi à l'issue de cela des
syndicats non signataires décident non
seulement de contester cet accord mais
en plus de bloquer l'outil de travail
bloquant ainsi aussi l'outil de travail
pour les salariés qui eux-mêmes se sont
engagés à travers un accord majoritaire
pour une hausse et salaire je vous
invite juste à envisager cette situation
pour ce qu'elle a d'inhabituel de
non-conformes au droit du travail non
conforme social du point de vue du
gouvernement cela justifie le recours à
des réquisitions qui n'ont rien
d'abusifs qui sont des réquisitions qui
seront juste nécessaires de manière à ce
que l'outil de travail l'outil productif
puisse retrouver ses pleine fonctions et
ses pleines missions et voyez que la
première ministre fait d'ailleurs le
distingo avec la situation d'un autre
groupe pour lequel un accord n'a pas
encore été trouvé et croyez à
l'engagement du gouvernement pour faire
en sorte que tout le monde se mette
autour de la table et discute de les
conditions d'un accord qui nous
permettrait une sortie de crise enfin
permettez-moi encore d'insister sur ce
point-là monsieur le sénateur ça ne vous
ai je crois jamais arriver en tant que
sénateur ou élu local d'aller contester
un accord en bonne et due forme signé
par des syndicats je le répète
majoritaire parce que le mot est
important
les salariés des groupes concernés ne
demandent pas une hausse de 52% de leurs
revenus à l'image de celle que le PDG de
Total énergie s'est octroyé il demande
leur part légitime en cette rentrée de
forte inflation la question du pouvoir
d'achat est devenue la première
préoccupation de nos concitoyens comment
pourrait-on s'en étonner vous allez
déposer deux amendements en loi de
finances qui devrait dégager nous dit-on
200 millions d'euros c'est très très
loin du compte il faut taxer fortement
les super profits pour aider les
salariés les retraités les entreprises
et les collectivités le ministre Bruno
Le Maire disait la semaine dernière dans
une interview à la Gazette je crois je
préfère le ciblage au saupoudrage sachez
que de ce côté de l'hémicycle nous
préférons le partage au bricolage
merci je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Michael et colimo est ok pour
le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
je me permets de saluer les collègues et
lui polynésiens qui sont dans la tribu
de l'honneur voilà Monsieur le
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers
[Musique]
du gouvernement et en particulier celle
du ministre Jean-François Carenco
pour sa bienveillance à recevoir la
délégation des élus de Wallis-et-Futuna
cette semaine à Paris
mais aussi pour l'impulsion donnée à la
reprise des travaux du quai de l'herbe
qui est un poumon pour l'île de foot
en réponse à ma demande de juillet
dernier bien sûr
je voudrais aussi profiter de cette
période de consultation générale
pour attirer votre attention sur la
situation sanitaire Wallis expo
comme vous le savez monsieur le ministre
depuis 2005 17 ans aucune politique de
prévention n'a été mise en place par
l'agence de santé ce qui a permis aux
maladies telles que le diabète et les
maladies cardiovasculaires de se
développer sur le terrain le rapport
IGAS de 2019
avait pourtant préconisé de mettre
l'accent sur la prévention
mais ce rapport est resté très officieux
et ce au détriment de notre population
je souhaite ici m'assurer que la
conférence de santé se tiendra au
premier semestre 2023
et associés à toutes les instances
locales et l'ensemble de la population
d'autre part monsieur le ministre le
lancement du volley santé du Conseil
national de la refondation doit aussi
être l'occasion de restaurer le lien de
confiance rompu entre la population et
l'Agence de santé
ne sont pas entendues les professionnels
de santé fuient le territoire
je souhaite enfin attirer votre
attention sur deux autres situations
prioritaires
premièrement celle des dialysés qui ont
besoin du renouvellement de oui
générateurs d'hémodialyse devenu
obsolète
et d'un véhicule adapté pour leur
transport
deuxièmement la concrétisation du projet
d'épargne avec un copilotage est un
territoire
aussi monsieur le ministre au regard de
ces éléments
comment le gouvernement entend t-il
aider Wallis espna à se doter d'un
système de santé et d'une organisation
des soins adaptés aux besoins de la
population je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole du cash monsieur le
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
Rhône
sur le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
culino est ok vous connaissez mon
attachement pour les territoires
ultramarins et leurs problèmes liés au
système de santé je l'ai dit dès que je
suis arrivé à ce ministère attachement
que que je partage avec Jean-François
carenko et nous suivons de près la
problématique de l'ensemble des
territoires d'outre-mer et bien entendu
Wallis-et-Futuna ne sera pas laissé pour
compte dans ces dans ces préoccupations
les problèmes sont sur le terrain j'ai
aussi l'habitude de dire que les
solutions sont sur le terrain et c'est
là qu'il faut aller les chercher dans ce
cadre le CNR santé qui a démarré la
semaine dernière
aura pleinement son rôle sur le
territoire de Wallis-et-Futuna en
associant les élus les citoyens les
professionnels de santé tout ceci sous
le couvert pour l'organisation de
l'Agence de santé et l'Agence de Santé
prendra toute sa part pour organiser ses
réunions bien entendu la conférence de
santé qui va se tenir et tout à fait
dans le cadre de ce CNR santé
sur le volet prévention vous savez que
c'est une politique à laquelle je tiens
beaucoup en tant que ministre de la
santé et de la prévention mais également
en tant que médecin je ne peux accepter
une situation où la prévention est
insatisfaisante et ne permet pas de
répondre aux besoins de santé de la
population je rappelle ici que 4 cancers
sur 10 et 8 maladies cardiovasculaires
sur 10 pourraient être évité simplement
par une bonne santé c'est-à-dire manger
correctement respirer correctement et
faire de l'exercice physique c'est ce à
quoi nous devons aboutir sur l'ensemble
du territoire national et bien entendu
aux outre-mer concernant le rapport et
gaz de 2019 juste pour vous rappeler
quand même que nous avons commencé à
mettre en place un pôle santé publique
et prévention au sein de l'agence que
des personnels ont été recrutés et que
les travaux vont enfin certes démarrer
sur une politique de prévention plus
ambitieuse concernant la problématique
de l'hémodialyse je vais voir de près ce
que vous évoquez sur ces problématiques
de postes démodialyse je vais rappeler
aussi que
pour Futuna des travaux ont débuté pour
un centre d'emodialyse qui seront fini
fin 2023 à 20 d'éviter des transferts
entre Futuna et Wallis des paris
évacuation sanitaires les problèmes sont
sur le terrain les solutions aussi j'en
suis persuadé avec l'ensemble des
citoyens et les élus
la parole est notre collègue Laurent
Duplomb pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre division de moitié
de la production de pommes explosion des
importations de poulet polonais et de
tomates marocaines chute des surfaces de
blé recul du cheptel laitier faute d'un
revenu suffisant des éleveurs c'est
incontestable la ferme France produit de
moins en moins depuis 2017 vous prenez
le tout monté en gamme plus de
contraintes et plus de charge quitte à
importer davantage depuis le discours de
Rungis du président voilà votre
politique vous faites fausse route vous
mettez en danger notre souveraineté
alimentaire pour tous les Français en
condamnant certains de nos citoyens a
acheté que des produits importés on
marche sur la tête notre manque de
compétitivité est la racine de nos mots
coût de la main d'oeuvre sur
transposition et sur administration
manque d'investissement signature
d'accord de libre-échange qui au lieu de
protéger condamne nos agriculteurs sans
parler du climat politique médiatique
délétère avec son flot de critiques
voilà le mal français monsieur le
ministre vous devez enfin agir il faut
inverser cette tendance que comptez-vous
faire
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs Duplomb je vois d'abord saluer
le la qualité du travail ce qui fait
cause vous avez fait que vous avez fait
au travers d'un rapport avec deux de vos
collègues je vous salue la qualité de ce
rapport qui pose un certain nombre de
diagnostics d'ailleurs le diagnostic que
vous posez parce que vous avez eu
l'honnêteté intellectuelle de le faire
il porte sur 32 années puisqu'il remonte
à 90 sur cette affaire de souveraineté
c'est si président de la République à 17
ministres qui se sont succédés donc
c'est manifestement un sujet depuis
longtemps qui est sur la table vous
évoquez plusieurs questions dans ce
report je vais en évoquer rapidement
dans le temps imparti quelques-unes
d'abord il y a la question de la
rémunération nous avons depuis 2017 au
travers de deux lois successives
également corrigés par égaline 2 essayez
de faire en sorte que nous ayons bien un
débat au travers de la rémunération ça
avait porté ses fruits jusqu'à ce que la
crise ukrainienne arrive mais pour la
première fois depuis 10 ans la
rémunération avait augmenté et on sait
très bien que la rémunération c'est la
base de la souveraineté alimentaire
parce que c'est la base du maintien du
monde agricole deuxième sujet sur lequel
je voudrais insister c'est que depuis
2017 nous avons mis en oeuvre deux
programmes massivement le premier c'est
le plan France relance qui se termine
1,5 milliards d'euros qui ont été
quasiment totalement concernés je viens
de faire la reventilation des dernières
enveloppes et donc c'est un milliard 5
d'euros pour moderniser l'outil de
production et dans France 2030 c'est
près de 3 milliards d'euros qui seront
mis à disposition pour l'innovation la
recherche et l'adaptation de
l'agriculture troisième élément il faut
qu'on travaille sur la souveraineté sur
les questions vous connaissez bien ce
sujet monsieur le sénateur qui sont les
questions d'eau au travers du varen de
l'autre trois dispositifs le système
assurantiel sur lequel vous avez
travaillé particulièrement ici au Sénat
pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
solidifier le système d'assurance
deuxième élément l'adaptation des
pratiques troisième élément c'est
l'accès à l'eau il faut désormais
déployer les projets parce que sans eau
il y aura pas d'agriculture et désormais
il faut qu'on le fasse concrètement sur
le terrain enfin il me semble que il
faut qu'on travaille sur deux sujets
complémentaires l'adaptation au
dérèglement climatique qui vient peu
puissamment impacter qui peut avoir des
conséquences sur la souveraineté des
modèles de production qui sont chahutés
on l'a vu régulièrement cet été et puis
dernier élément il y aura pas de
souveraineté alimentaire et pas de
souveraineté tout court si on n'arrive
pas à procéder au renouvellement des
générations et donc il faut leur donner
des perspectives
monsieur Duplomb
monsieur le ministre tout ça
malheureusement c'est des mots et on
voit pas beaucoup d'actions monsieur le
ministre ce qui nous arrive sur
l'énergie nous allons le connaître sur
l'alimentation alors je ne suis pas un
arc simplement paysan mais comme
beaucoup de Français j'en ai marre de
cette technocratie abrutissante qui
finira pour résoudre notre problème de
souveraineté de nous condamner à ne
manger qu'un jour par semaine plutôt que
de la décroissance il nous faut un vrai
choc de compétitivité madame la Première
ministre après le théâtre guignol du col
roulé ou de la doudoune enfilez enfin
vos bottes pour comprendre la situation
préoccupante dans laquelle notre
agriculture se trouve merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jérôme Durin pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur la commission
des Lois du Sénat décidait la création
d'une mission d'information pour
examiner l'opportunité de la
réorganisation de la police judiciaire
on aurait pu imaginer que cette
initiative qui a inspiré l'Assemblée
nationale vous permette de recréer les
conditions d'un dialogue serein que
constate-t-on un mois après la
mobilisation de la PJ que le DGPN a
minoré ne faiblit pas fâché par une
vidéo ce dernier a d'ailleurs limogé le
patron de la PJ marseillaise résultat la
contestation s'étend et devient visible
dans la rue vous citez des rapports
parlementaires et des ministres pour
justifier votre réforme mais aucun de
ces rapports et aucun de vos
prédécesseurs n'était parvenu à
inquiéter l'ensemble de la PJ même la PJ
parisienne dont vous rappelez qu'elle
n'est pas concernée soutient le
mouvement vous incriminez la proximité
des élections syndicales pour justifier
ce climat tout en affirmant que tous les
syndicats soutiennent votre réforme hier
même les très discrets procureurs on
renouvelé leur opposition à cette
réforme considérant que ce projet
constitue une remise en cause de la
place accordée à l'autorité judiciaire
gardienne de la liberté individuelle
dans un état de droit monsieur le
ministre n'est-ce pas le moment de
revoir votre copie
pour vous répondre la parole l'état
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur des
outreberges monsieur Darmanin merci
monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur nous travaillons en ce moment
même dans un esprit je crois à
constructif sur la loi d'orientation et
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur et nous avons eu des longs
débats mais évidemment devant vos
collègues je veux revenir sur cette
réforme de la police nationale qui est
nécessaire et qui est attendu depuis
plus de 35 ans par divers rapports 7
j'en ai compté sénatoriaux de toute
tendance politique confondues j'en ai
fait la démonstration hier et lancer par
le ministre Joxe
alors revenons au ministre Jox
j'en viens aux questions posées par
Monsieur Hennel monsieur le Président
dit le ministre jeu de ce 26 novembre
1990 au Sénat débat en faisant foi le
fait de nommer un directeur
départemental de la police nationale a
été accueilli avec curiosité parfois
inquiétude y compris chez certains
fonctions de la police nationale
notamment les commissaires
cela ne porte en rien atteinte veut se
garder saut au principe fondamental
selon lequel la police judiciaire est à
la disposition de la justice et
travaille bien sûr sur le contrôle du
parquet ou sur les instructions d'une
commission obligatoire délivrée par un
juge d'instruction aujourd'hui les
services de la préjudiciaire sont placés
sur l'autorité des chefs de service
régionaux de la police judiciaire et du
DCPJ le préfet en tant que chef de
l'ensemble des services de l'État est
parfois des services ministères de
l'Intérieur dans le département aura
autorité sur eux dans les actes mesure
où il peut avoir autorité sur des
services de fonctionnaires jusqu'au
moment précis où ces derniers se
trouvent placés en départ la loi sous
l'autorité de la justice à cet égard
malgré les inquiétudes exprimées par les
fonctionnaires de police rien ne sera
modifié il est vrai que c'est Monsieur
Pasqua qui a mis fin à cette excellente
réforme
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous renvoyez à ce
qui s'est passé il y a 30 ans je vous
parle de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
notre mission sénatorial se prononcera
au fond mais il y a à minima un problème
de méthode les policiers ne réagissent
pas par corporatisme ce qui est en jeu
c'est la séparation des pouvoirs et le
modèle français d'enquête la police
judiciaire sous l'autorité du préfet
c'est le risque d'abandonner les
enquêtes complexes la criminité
organisée devant le flux inexorable du
quotidien monsieur Darmanin on connaît
votre grand talent mais aujourd'hui à
part vous personne ne semble soutenir
cette réforme
merci
la parole
est à notre collègue Jacques gros Perrin
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale le 13 juillet
dernier je vous interrogé en commission
de la culture sur mes vive inquiétude
concernant votre ministère les
situations de l'école en France après
votre nomination je vous demandais de
nous rassurer trois mois plus tard mes
inquiétudes demeurent le président de la
République a décidé lui-même de lancer
l'année scolaire en réunissant les
acteurs et les réacteurs d'académie
pensez-vous que les lampes pour
transformer l'école doit être si
puissant qui ne puisse venir que du chef
de l'État cette verticalité interroge
sur votre rôle et vos marges de manœuvre
tout en posant de nouveau la question
rupture ou continuité après votre
prédécesseur monsieur le ministre les
fait les réalités vous rattrapent la
rentrée scolaire n'a pas été à la
hauteur il n'y avait pas un enseignant
devant chaque classe et donc a été même
formé en quatre jours les difficultés de
terrain se multiplient des enchantements
général des enseignants et aux et
signalements pour atteinte à la laïcité
votre communication prudente elle est
encore insuffisante
la communauté éducative a besoin d'une
directive clair d'être soutenu d'une
volonté politique ferme ou récent propos
à l'étranger vont également inquiété
vous avez monsieur le ministre pensif
pouvoir affirmer à New York du site qui
est des traces d'anti-américanisme dans
les discours politique français vous
avez suggéré la possibilité d'évoquer
avec nuance ces inégalités raciales de
notre pays non monsieur le ministre la
France n'est pas raciste nous sommes
nous aussi aux questions sensibles aux
questions d'inégalité n'abîmez pas les
trois génocopies fondateurs cessez de
vous positionner comme universitaire
militante ne tendez pas de nous imposer
un wauquisme de salon chair à notre
président Retailleau incompatible avec
vos responsabilités politiques soyez
ministres et enfin la seule question qui
s'impose monsieur le ministre quel est
votre vision de l'école où voulez-vous
emmener les enseignants et nos enfants
pour vous répondre la parole étape
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse Monsieur
papendaye Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gros Perrin
monsieur le sénateur vous m'aviez
interrogé à ce sujet devant la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation et je veux bien répondre
à nouveau mais il est important de
prendre le temps 2 minutes ce sera
difficile de se plonger dans la
réflexion et de ne pas simplement
extraire des citations approximatives
que j'ai vu circuler ici et là j'ai déjà
dit
et j'ai eu l'occasion de le redire à
quel point j'étais moi-même un enfant de
la République et que je devais à peu
près tout à l'école publique et je
demeure profondément reconnaissants à
son égard je suis aussi de ceux qui
estiment que lutter contre les
différentes formes de discrimination
contre le racisme contre l'antisémitisme
ou la haine anti LGBT n'affaiblit pas la
République mais la renforce c'est une
manière pour moi d'exprimer concrètement
notre attachement aux valeurs qui sont
les nôtres celle de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité et de laïcité la laïcité j'y
tiens la loi de 2004 est et sera
respectée fermement et avec transparence
je vous ai dit aussi mon attachement une
république fidèle à ses valeurs celle
des droits humains il y a une république
qui non contente d'inscrire ces
principes aux frontispices de ces
bâtiments les met en oeuvre en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse je ne suis pas simplement
attaché à la lettre mais aussi à la mise
en oeuvre concrète des politiques de
cohésion sociale de réussite pour tous
les élèves et d'égalité des chances
alors vous le voyez monsieur le sénateur
ici point de hockisme de salon mais mon
seul attachement en tant que citoyen en
tant que ministre aux valeurs
universelles de la République
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
monsieur le ministre nous sommes ici
tous des enfants de la République tous
des enfants de la République vous pouvez
pas vous targuer de l'être simplement
mais je tiens à vous dire néanmoins
néanmoins vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question sur votre vision de l'école et
les Français attendent la vision de
l'école en minutes mais on attend ça
fait quelques mois que vous avez été élu
en tout cas choisi par le Président de
la République et enfin les défis sont en
tout cas vos mots ne répondent à ce
moment ni à l'effondrement de la
connaissance et la crise de la
transmission ni aux immenses défis
posées à l'école monsieur le ministre
apporté à votre ministère apporter aux
Français la sérénité dont nous avons
besoin merci
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
Antoine Lévy pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
ministre chargée de l'organisation
territoriale et de la santé madame la
ministre nombreuses sont les maires
confrontés au fléau des déserts médicaux
et la transformation du numérique
clausus en numéro sapertuis ce n'est pas
prête de produire ses effets face à
cette situation les mères cherchent
désespérément des médecins français ou
européens pour leurs administrer mais
devant les échecs à répétition ils se
mettent finalement en quête de médecin
hors Union Européenne ou sont sollicités
par ces mêmes médecins pour venir
si certains ont des pistes pour faire
venir un médecin étranger francophone
ils abandonnent souvent leur démarche
découragé par les difficultés
administratives ça se demandait si tout
n'est pas fait pour décourager leur
venue en des asphictions par des
démarches complexes dont il arrive
souvent pas voir l'issue pour ne pas
paraître autocentré sur mon département
bien qu'il soit tout aussi concerné je
vais prendre l'exemple de la commune des
Pyrénées-Orientales la Tour de France
mes collègues gens sur les François
Calvi connaissent très certainement
cette histoire
cette ville n'a plus de médecin
généraliste depuis le 22 octobre 2021
situation de minuit malheureusement
banale dans nos territoires ruraux le
maire avait pourtant réussi à trouver un
médecin pour sa commune mais celui-ci
libanais et exerce actuellement à
Beyrouth le docteur en question est prêt
à quitté le Liban pour s'installer à la
Tour de France il a 30 ans d'expérience
et affirme en plus une partie de ses
études à Lyon seulement voilà depuis le
début de l'année le ministère de la
Santé bloc son dossier laissant le maire
dans l'incompréhension
cet exemple il a pas isolé je suis bien
ensemble de nos territoires ruraux qui
est confronté à ces difficultés contenu
d'attention qui règne en France en
matière d'accès aux soins nous
devrions-nous pas songer à favoriser
l'implantation de ces médecins non
communautaires en facilitant de façon
dérogatoire les procédures
administratives sur la porterait ainsi
une réponse même partielle la crise des
désirs médicaux pourquoi par exemple ne
pas organiser 5 indices concours
d'évaluation des connaissances et
compétences par an au lieu de une à deux
actuellement répondant à la pénurie de
médecins passera forcément par de
multiples dispositifs celui-ci en est un
parmi tant d'autres aussi madame la
ministre pourriez-vous nous indiquer ce
que compte faire le Gouvernement en la
matière je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est à la ministre
délégué en charge de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
madame Firmin o monsieur le Président
Mesdames et sénatrices messieurs le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur Lévy la
loi de 2019 portant sur l'organisation
et transformation du site de notre
système de santé dite au TSS a posé les
bases d'un nouveau dispositif de
reconnaissance des padus des
professionnels exercer Orion européenne
comme vous l'avez signalé avec deux
procédures distinctes la première
procédure avec un nom
usuel pas très joli je vous le conseille
le stock pour les praticiens qui
exercaient dans nos établissements de
santé avant 2019 et parfois depuis très
longtemps a été mise en place une
procédure de régularisation pour
s'assurer de leur compétences une
procédure pour le flux pour les
praticiens souhaitant venir depuis 2019
a été mise en place pour une épreuve de
vérification des connaissances avec un
parcours de consolidation de la pratique
la crise sanitaire a malheureusement
empêché l'organisation des commissions
d'autorisation en raison de la forte
mobilisation des membres du jury qui
sont des professionnels de santé et des
candidats eux-mêmes qui sont des
professionnels de santé dans les
établissements santé et on peut s'en
féliciter au 1er octobre 2022 il reste
2400 dossiers à traiter selon cette
procédure à la demande du gouvernement
je tiens à saluer l'engagement de
l'ordre des médecins et de la Commission
nationale de gestion de mettre et de
renforcer les dispositifs des effectifs
afin de traiter le plus grand nombre de
dossiers avant la date butoir du 31
décembre 2022 posé dans la loi au TSS
malheureusement nous savons que ces 2400
dossiers ne pourront être retraités
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement a
déposé dans le cadre du PLFSS un
amendement qui prolonge jusqu'au 31 mars
2023 la gestion de ce de ce stock au 31
mars 2023 le stock sera effectif sera
géré sur la procédure du flux nous
serons vigilants la première session a
eu lieu en 2022 nous sommes en train de
tirer les retours de sexe des
expériences d'expérience de cette
gestion de flux et nous allons en lien
avec les ARS le cnome le CNG et le
syndicat des Padu répondre au mieux à
cette gestion du flux sur lequel nous
devons apporter des ammonérations
la parole de notre collègue Olivier
Pacaud
pour le groupe les républicains
merci Michel le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
un brin cohérence et de bon sens n'a
jamais nuit surtout à un gouvernement
alors où la défiance populaire envers la
parole publique et atteint des sommets
mieux vaut une République exemplaire
permettez-moi donc de m'interroger sur
une contradiction de votre gouvernance
une règle certes informelle mais
inlassablement répété depuis 25 ans veut
qu'un ministre abandonne c'est mandat
exécutif locaux avec une mission à un
objectif simple se consacrer entièrement
à sa mission gouvernementale l'immense
majorité de votre gouvernement s'est
plié à cette règle rejoignant ainsi les
parlementaires pour qui le non cumule et
non pas une règle mais une loi que le
précédent gouvernement auquel vous
apparteniez à refuser d'assouplir l'an
dernier cependant il reste quelques
récalcitrants
mère président d'assemblée ultra-marine
président d'agglomération et même
président d'un département dans le cas
du ministre des Armées y aura-t-il donc
des ministres privilégiés de fortes
têtes capricieuses un problème
d'autorité de votre part Madame le
Ministre comptez-vous enfin faire
appliquer cette règle que le mini le
chef de l'État lui-même avait rappelé en
2017 allez vous faire démissionner de
leur mandats locaux les ministres
concernés
pour vous répondre la parole est Obélix
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer Gérald
Darmanin
les bras les braconniers étant les
meilleurs garde de chasse à votre
question monsieur le sénateur Pacaud
d'abord je voudrais vous dire que au nom
du gouvernement et bien sûr de la
première ministre les règles seront
respectées plusieurs ministres ont déjà
démissionné de leur fonction exécutives
et ils ont quelques semaines à demander
la première ministre pour pouvoir
convoquer leurs assemblées délibérantes
afin de démissionner toutes et tous de
leur exécutif tout en restant évidemment
conseiller municipal conseil
départemental au conseil régional
j'espère que vous ne reprochez pas mon
gouvernement que vous évoquez parfois un
peu distant du terrain d'être par
ailleurs élu faudra pas non plus que ce
soit une tare vérité ici
mensonge au-delà monsieur le sénateur
Paco une fois que j'ai rappelé cette
règle qui je crois peut vous plaire j'ai
compris qu'il y avait aussi une question
de départementale dans votre question et
que sans doute la ministre de votre
département auquel vous partagiez
j'imagine un moment de sympathie lors de
l'assemblée des mères de samedi dernier
dans le l'Oise purée si vous rappeler
que la règle évoquée bien sûr est
informelle mais a toujours connu plus
exceptions le ministre Jean-Yves Le
Drian a été ministre de la Défense tout
en étant président de la Région Bretagne
il me semble d'ailleurs que le président
Nicolas Sarkozy a été très longuement
ministre de l'intérieur tout en étant
mère de Neuilly ou puis président du
conseil départemental des Hauts-de-Seine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur Paco
madame la Première ministre je félicite
le bon élève l'ancien maire de Tourcoing
d'avoir répondu et nous avons tous pris
notre que les ministres rebelles
démissionnerait bientôt reste
nous ne voulons pas de parole nous
voulons des actes c'est ce que mérite
nos citoyens et nos territoires et la
question d'autorité est d'exemplarité
sont la clé du problème comment
voulez-vous Madame le Ministre être obéi
entre guillemets des français quand un
ministre effrontément Bafou la règle et
quel comble de voir l'armée ou le sens
de la hiérarchie de la discipline sont
les valeurs cardinales dirigées par un
ministre rebelle à la commune voilà
l'exemplarité de se proclame pas elle se
pratique
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Gisèle Jourda pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et République
président ma question s'adresse à la
madame la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
face à l'internationalisation du conflit
à l'Ukraine à sa dramatique
densification
quels sont les initiatives les actions
que compte mener la France
allons-nous continuer à rechercher une
issue diplomatique allons-nous décider
d'augmenter notre contribution
humanitaire financière ou militaire cela
en prend le chemin quand la France vient
d'annoncer qu'elle renforçait sa
présence militaire en Roumanie dans le
cadre de l'OTAN allons-nous tenter de
peser sur le G7 mais que peut décider le
G7 réunit en urgence sinon réitérer un
affichage de solidarité allons nous
faire la promotion de nouvelles
sanctions
je partage les mots du président de la
République nous insistons à un
changement profond de la nature de cette
guerre et ce surtout car le Bélarus
s'apprête à véritablement devenir la
base armée et le faire de lance de la
politique russe dans la gradation du
conflit
il serait bien avisé de ne pas entrer
dans la guerre ce sont vos mots madame
la ministre
misk ce n'est pas seulement le nom des
accords qui n'ont pas abouti c'est
surtout la capitale d'un pays martyre
dans l'angle mort de nos actualités
alors que s'il joue la vie de plusieurs
centaines de prisonniers politiques donc
je veux faire raisonner le nom et saluer
le courage madame la ministre à l'aune
du conflit qui nous plonge tous à leur
internationale européenne comment
apprécier le fléchissement de la
politique du Belarus je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre de l'Europe de faire
étrangère Madame Catherine Colonna
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrice Jourdain vous
avez raison depuis lundi et encore
aujourd'hui la Russie a lancé une série
de frappe sur le territoire ukrainien
qui vise principalement les
infrastructures civiles et qui ont sans
doute pour objectif également
d'atteindre le moral de la population
ukrainienne alors la France la réaffirmé
son soutien à l'Ukraine se poursuivra et
il sanctifie il s'intensifie nous aidons
l'Ukraine dans sa résistance militaire
mais nous l'aidons aussi dans sa
résilience civile sa capacité à tenir et
sa capacité à tenir notamment à
l'approche de l'hiver
notre soutien porte sur tous les
domaines économiques à hauteur déjà de 2
milliards d'euros humanitaire avec pour
la France plus de 200 millions d'euros
mobilisés et bien sûr militaires avec de
nouvelles décisions encore annoncées par
le ministre des Armées vous l'avez dit
mais c'est aussi un soutien politique et
diplomatique qui se poursuit car il y a
un agresseur et un agressé alors hier
les dirigeants du G7 ont condamné les
dernières attaques russes qu'ils ont
qualifiés de crimes de guerre et on dit
que leur responsable devront rendre des
comptes ce soir ou dans la nuit
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
se prononcera sans ambiguïté sur
l'annexion illégale de territoire
ukrainien par la Russie montrant une
fois de plus son isolement l'isolement
de la Russie et je réponds indirectement
madame la sénatrice à votre question sur
le Belarus qui en effet ne doit pas
s'engager davantage dans son soutien à
l'opération
illégal menée par la Russie et ce
soutien c'est aussi le soutien de
l'Union européenne qui a mobilisé déjà
plus de 9 milliards d'euros qui a porté
la facilité européenne de paix de
milliards et demi d'euros et qui a
adoptait déjà 8 séries de sanctions pour
peser sur l'effort de guerre russe je
vous le dis il y aura si nécessaire
d'autres sanctions ce soutien s'inscrira
dans la durée pour que l'Ukraine
recouvre sa souveraineté je vous le
redis madame la sénatrice après le
président de la République après la
première ministre nous serons à côté de
l'Ukraine aussi longtemps que nécessaire
je vous remercie
madame la ministre n'oublions pas qu'il
faut absolument stopper cette guerre
sortir certes du conflit et vous en avez
donné donc les perspectives mais surtout
n'oublions pas de retrouver des
perspectives de paix et pour retrouver
des perspectives de paix après avoir
stoppé la guerre il faut savoir
continuer à se parler
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Cédric Vial pour le groupe les
républicains
merci ce Président mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Papin
Guy me disent de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre l'inclusion des
élèves en situation du handicap à
l'école est une priorité c'est aussi un
défi pour lequel nous sommes tous
mobilisés depuis la loi de 2005 pourtant
cette rentrée scolaire ne s'est pas
déroulée pour beaucoup de ses enfants
comme toutes les autres
en effet depuis septembre et suite à une
décision de justice sollicitée et
obtenue par votre prédécesseur l'Etat
c'est désengagé du suivi et de la prise
en charge de ses enfants a besoin
particulier sur le temps périscolaire et
celui de la cantine s'il s'agit une fois
encore d'un transfert de charge de
l'État vers les collectivités sans
compensation la question financière
n'est pas de très loin le problème
principal le plus important et le
transfert de responsabilité et cet
étrange vision du suivi d'un enfant ou
ce n'est plus ni lui ni ses besoins qui
sont au cœur de cet accompagnement mais
le temps sur lequel il est exercé
scolaire ou périscolaire monsieur le
ministre probablement faudra-t-il revoir
en profondeur la politique d'inclusion
des enfants et adolescent en situation
de handicap dont le nombre a plus que
quadruplé en 20 ans pour atteindre 430
000 enfants à cette rentrée soit environ
trois et demi pour cent des effectifs
totaux un élève en moyenne par classe
monsieur le ministre êtes-vous prêt à
vous engager pour mettre en place des
conventions de mise à disposition d'aesh
sur le temps de midi signé entre votre
ministère et les mers ce qui
favoriserait le recrutement et leur
formation et permettrait un suivi de
qualité des enfants concernés le Conseil
d'État recommande cette solution la loi
la permet les maires de France la
réclament Jean-Michel Blanquer l'avait
promise pourtant votre administration
refuse de la mettre en place
de fait
de fait depuis la rentrée des enfants ne
sont pas accompagnés les familles sont
inquiète les équipes éducatives sont
déstabilisées monsieur le ministre le
plus grand des handicaps c'est d'être
absent là où notre présence est utile
pour vous répondre la parole de
communiste de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Cédric Vial vous avez raison
l'école inclusive est une des grandes
réussites du système scolaire avec
l'inclusion de plus de 430
000 élèves en situation de handicap dans
le milieu scolaire ordinaire depuis 2005
une croissance de plus de 25% depuis
2017 pour les accueillir nous avons
notamment recruter un grand nombre d'Ash
ils sont au nombre de 130
000 cette année avec un rythme de
recrutement de 4000 par an 4000 l'année
prochaine si toutefois vous approuvez le
PLF 2023 nous avons des difficultés en
la matière y compris liés au fait que
les notifications parlaient MDPH peuvent
survenir très tard jusqu'à la dernière
minute avant la rentrée et nous devons
donc en quelque courir derrière une
marée de notification qui crée des
difficultés pour les familles et pour
les élèves je le reconnais volontiers
vous faites allusion à une question
particulière qui est celle de la pose
méridienne et vous avez raison de
mentionner l'arrêt du Conseil d'État du
20 novembre 2020 qui nous en juin de
rémunérer les aesh sur le temps scolaire
et non pas sur le temps périscolaire et
donc nous devons trouver la solution et
la solution est complexe d'un point de
vue juridique pour assurer la continuité
cette solution est étudiée par les
services et ça n'est pas mauvaise
volonté de notre part nous reconnaissons
évidemment l'intérêt qu'il y a à
maintenir la continuité particulièrement
pour certains types de handicap je pense
ici aux enfants en situation
autistique 11% du total qui ont besoin
de continuité donc ce à quoi je m'engage
monsieur
sénateur c'est en collaboration avec les
collectivités les services juridiques
concernés à trouver la solution adéquate
nous sommes sur le point d'y arriver de
manière à assurer la meilleure solution
pour les enfants en situation de
handicap
si je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Daphné rachmadou pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste vous avez la parole
de se connaître
gue monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des Transports
monsieur le ministre la France connaît
aujourd'hui des grèves parmi les
grévistes figurent les aiguillières du
rail ceux des Hauts de France
aujourd'hui mais ce d'Occitanie les ont
précédés au printemps leur doléances est
simple il réclame des embauches parce
que notre système est totalement
obsolète il faut encore des personnes
physiques pour assurer l'aiguillages des
trains sur ce sujet de modernisation du
rail nous avons 40 ans de retard
moderniser notre rail c'est mettre en
place de nouveaux systèmes de
signalisation à commencer par le système
européen de gestion du trafic
ferroviaire c'est aussi regrouper la
gestion des 2200 aiguillages dans 16
postes de commandes centralisée du
réseau digitalisé
c'est enfin numériser le système de
gestion de transport pour combler cette
lacune un énorme effort d'investissement
doit être consenti aujourd'hui
c'est à dire au pire moment puisque
parallèlement la flambée du coude
l'électricité plombe les dépenses de
fonctionnement des autorités
organisatrices de transport à l'exemple
en Île-de-France ce surcourt représente
950 millions d'euros pour boucler le
budget 2023 l'essentiel de cette somme
n'étant pas financée le spectre
récemment agité d'un passe Navigo
augmenté à 100 euros inquiète je le dis
ici car je sais que nous partageons tous
ce point il n'est évidemment pas
question de pénaliser davantage les
usagers
dans ces conditions il est légitime de
craindre un effet de vaste communicant
entre des choix d'investissement et de
fonctionnement ce dernier phagocytan le
premier ce faisant c'est aussi une
remise en cause de notre chemin vers la
neutralité carbone car le report modal
sur le train est un axe clé de la
stratégie gouvernementale aussi Monsieur
le Ministre avez-vous identifié une
telle menace et comment comptez-vous y
répondre d'un point de vue budgétaire
en charge des transports monsieur
Clément Beaune vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Rachman vous avez raison de
souligner ces deux points qui sont
extrêmement importants et que je venais
en moins bien distinguer même si vous
avez noté les effets de contagion ou de
vases communicants comme vous les avez
indiqué il y en a pas je veux d'abord
inciter là-dessus sur la question du
réseau nous avons rappelé depuis la
formation du gouvernement sur l'autorité
de la première mise l'importance de
notre investissement la modernisation et
la régénération du réseau c'est en effet
essentiel et il est vrai que la France
sur ce point précis un réseau en moyenne
plus vieux que celui des grands pays
européens qui nous entourent et c'est la
raison pour laquelle depuis maintenant
plusieurs années nous portons un effort
budgétaire extrêmement important
puisqu'il y a 5 ans nous étions à moins
de 2 milliards et demi d'investissement
par an dans le réseau ferroviaire dans
le nouveau contrat de performance nous
sommes à 2,9 milliards d'euros par an
sur 10 ans faut-il accélérer faut-il
aller plus loin nous allons le regarder
avec notamment les niveau du comité
d'orientation des infrastructures mais
la priorité est très claire cela n'est
pas la même chose en effet que l'offre
de transport et que le fonctionnement
notamment affecté par les coûts
d'énergie dans certains cas parce que le
sujet est grave et parce que le sujet
est important nous devons être très
clair vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens sur
les responsabilités pour ne pas être
dans un jeu de posture qui est
responsable de l'organisation des
transports dans la région Île-de-France
comme dans les autres régions c'est Île
de France mobilité c'est la région
elle-même
est-ce que la région a été soutenue par
l'État ces dernières années oui plus
qu'aucune autre en France c'était sans
doute légitime et normal plus de 2
milliards d'euros de subventions et
d'avance remboursables depuis le début
de la crise covid je ne le conteste pas
c'était indispensable mais cela doit
être rappelé car c'est un peu oublié
parfois dans le débat public de ces
derniers jours et donc le prix du Pass
Navigo pour être très concret ne dépend
pas de l'état je tiens à le rappeler
parce que il est un peu facile de nous
dire que c'est nous qui le fixons
peut-être que ce serait mieux au moins
bien fait je n'en sais rien mais ça
n'est pas nous donc chacun doit
s'assumer ses responsabilités une fois
qu'on a dit cela je l'ai dit la prison
de Pécresse je ne jouerai aucun jeu de
renvoi de responsabilité c'est une
responsabilité commune de faire
fonctionner dans les semaines qui
viennent dans les mois qui viennent pour
les Jeux Olympiques et Paralympiques et
bien au-delà nos réseaux franciliens
nous auront un contrat de plan état
région investirons les tâches sera
encore au rendez-vous dans la clarté
merci nous en avons terminé avec les
questions gouvernement nos prochaines
questions auront lieu le mercredi 19
octobre
je vais suspendre la séance sera reprise
à 16h30 pour la suite du projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur la séance est
suspendue